I never forget it was the first Michael
Jordan cover was it 11. that was the
first time I had my own copy this
basketball game is next level
the first one was super easy so you just
really giving a good spanking to
somebody
but you shouldn't have made that let's
be let's be real
let's see what we get let's start again
who you feel me
everywhere okay that was for the
beginners you know just to show
beginning stuff go we're going to show
you how I do I use Shaq you know what
I'm saying Shaq is is is Unstoppable and
he's a really nice person so we
definitely gonna rock with that I wanna
I wanna change my shooting guard too oh
we do I want Klay Thompson he ain't
gonna miss I'm getting Klay Thompson
he's another one of those guys who just
won't let you down not saying that jelly
Brown looks down because Jaylen Brown is
a very turn I saw him playing high
school he's from same counties man he
played my high school and he sure had
beat the breaks off of them I'll tell
you that
this this is to me the most the most fun
competitive game well I'm fine this is
our thing this is like this is what
bring the boys together I'll be I'll be
with it I started playing my team two
years ago to me I ain't gonna lie I find
it to be way more fun playing with like
just the people you think are cool and
in that position
I like people who are unapologetically
themselves there's a lot of that in the
in this era basketball with the new guys
Shaw kuzma they come when they walking
into that Court man they mommy Allen
Iverson a lot Sean's name is so studious
shy gillius Alexander that's a studious
name very articulate
I love Kevin Kevin Durant too he's also
unapologetically himself in the way of
not trying to impress anyone any guy
with no earrings I wouldn't know James
you ain't worried about no brush you
know what I'm saying like he just
pulling up I used to see him songs and
like get his opinion on stuff because
he's he's big on music you know what I'm
saying he got a good ear what would it
mean for you you got you're on my pink
Garden I think it's sick I mean
obviously I'm still flexing it baby I
think it's great if I could share this
greatness with the world because it's
too much greatness or like a height
modification
uh raise it up a couple inches
preferably LeBron arms yeah I won't like
like I want to come out
only like LeBron with my face you know
what I'm saying
[Music]